ça fonctionne en bluetooth donc quand je
vais approcher de l'alena sur la
passerelle automatiquement accéder à son
appartement avec son téléphone c'est le
futur qu'envisagent les résidences
yvelines essonne le bailleur social des
deux départements
aujourd'hui on part du principe que la
modernité va être tout ce qu'ils les
nouvelles technologies le numérique qui
va permettre d'apporter des services
supplémentaires aux locataires et
rendent les logements aussi attractif
d'un point de vue conforme capteurs sur
les portes et fenêtres calcul de la
température de l'humidité ou encore des
dépenses énergétiques du foyer des
installations adaptable en fonction des
besoins des locataires familles
personnes âgées ou à mobilité réduite
près de 7500 euros c'est le montant
estimé pour équiper les futurs logements
on est d'ailleurs en a vocation à loger
des personnes
donc on doit bien les loger et comme en
plus de ça les personnes sont si
modestes
c'est une question aussi d'éthique pour
nous que de leur apporter le même niveau
de confort si ce n'est au niveau de
confort plus élevé que dans le parc
privé
ces deux petites électrodes canton les
façons quand octave road again de l'eau
et en venir
m'alerter sur mon téléphone rouge et une
suite est aussi coupé l'eau deux projets
vont être lancés d'ici la fin de l'année
à chanteloup les vignes au val-fourré à
mantes-la-jolie les résidences yvelines
essonne héberge actuellement près deux
cents mille locataires sur les deux
départements